[Musique]
les ânes les ânes gré simple
bonsoir madame verner bonsoir je
m'appelle shon
c'est un plaisir mais d'y établir notre
maison est super
un vrai don de dieu je m'attendais à une
personne plus âgée
peut-être plus normal aussi on espère
que tu vas vite sentir chez toi dans
notre raison je parie que jéricho et toi
allez vous entendre à merveille
et elle trouve pas ça bizarre il est au
courant de la situation
je crois qu'il faut qu'on parle là les
partis qui peut poser ça sur la table je
suis bien comme je suis monsieur
dernière on a perdu dit ricco quand il
avait 13 semaines
ça a été dur prônera dit c'est la seule
chose qu'il est qu il est l'heure que
j'en end jéricho faire sa promenade vous
avez engager une nounou pour une poupée
est ce que tu l'as trouvé
elle est merveilleuse avec dit ricco et
si mon bébé lui fait confiance alors moi
aussi
ces messieurs vous on expliquer quoi sur
ce qui s'est passé
[ __ ] si jamais elle se réveille
s'ils allaient se souvient de ce qui
s'est passé
[Musique]
savez vous au moins
qui vous avait fait venir dans votre
demeure
chaque soir au moment de l'endormir
le père de sofia devient de prince de
ces histoires
alors on est et où déjà on 30 sites en
inde en ligne à côté dit of magic
voilà ça
[Musique]
des belles histoires d'anthony ce monde
imaginaire n'appartient qu'à eux
leur aventure peuplé de chevalier de
dragon zedda l'échangé en arrivant in
sauf sa princesse et sa jamais ça ne
changera
je mets
comme aux abats d'histoire apajh amusant
ça messieurs on pouvait pas rentrer
l'histoire va commencer pas bon le
prince varié je suis le prince il arrive
segosa tu en veux pas bien sûr que non
bonne nuit
[Musique]
depuis des siècles presque tous les
humains avaient perdu la capacité de
voir certains disent que la vue leur a
été enlevé par dieu pour guérir la terre
pour le peu d'hommes qui reste la vision
est seulement un mythe mais après tant
d'années le pouvoir de la vue est revenu
c'est quoi ça quelque chose est
différent les enfants ils ont la
capacité de voir
mes enfants ils n'ont pas pouvoir qui
s'apparenterait à de la magie ou de la
sorcellerie
protéger
depuis des siècles nous vivons dans la
crainte de ce jour pouvoir démoniaque de
la lumière a déjà presque failli
anéantir
pour trouver les enfants capables de
voir
et ramenez moi
il montrant l'assaut si on livre au
tracker des enfants il ne s'en prendront
pas nous non je soutiens pas ma bosse
[Musique]
saison qui sont un cadeau
la connaissance celle qui commence à un
monde nouveau
nous sommes une famille
nous ne faisons qu'un
nous battons ensemble
[Musique]
je dois vous mettre en sécurité même
moment et harry
c'est incroyable comme tout peut
basculer en si peu de temps et changer
un monde entier
[Applaudissements]
winner estates d'âme à ce matériau on
n'en sait rien il répète toujours les
mêmes salades c'est pas parce que tu es
premier ministre que tu peux te
permettre de déformer la réalité
quelqu'un dans ce bâtiment a trahi son
gouvernement et sa patrie
[Musique]
s'il s'avère que vous avez caché des
informations vous serez poursuivis pour
atteinte à la loi sur le secret d'état
catherine gun qui a pu d'après vous
révéler le mail de cosa j'ai quelque
chose que tu dois avoir dit à filer ça
une me fais gaffe
si le mémo est vrai la voile sur toi
peut envoyer en prison vous êtes une
espionne vous travaillez pour le
gouvernement britannique
non moi je travaille pour les
britanniques je ne recueille pas des
données électroniques pour que l'état
mentent aux prix tech
les renseignements sont peut-être
manipuler pour que l'angleterre entend
dire ce journal doit arrêter de prendre
ce que dit blair pour argent comptant
vous n'aviez rien à gagner et tout à
perdre c'est passible d'une peine de
prison
voulez vous prendre ce risque cette
guerre est historiquement impopulaire
savuth partout dans le monde entier la
plus grande manif de l'histoire de
l'humanité
si on ne rend pas ça public
ça reviendrait à dire que personne n'a
le droit de prévenir les britanniques
quand leur gouvernement lormand
[Musique]
ce que vous avez fait
c'est extraordinaire
cette guerre
est illégal
le public pas de droit de savoir
pourquoi mon avis
était d'empêcher une guerre et sauver
des vies je dois dire la vérité
je n'ai qu'un objectif puis sur l'agent
et c'est le pouvoir devenir un grand
écrivain de devoir arrêter ce genre de
saint jean
c'est sûr que c'est une sauvageonne
conduire à cette famille à sa perte elle
ne sait pas se tenir comme une jeune
fille bien élevée
[Musique]
merci mais ça va
si j'étais avec toi
elle devrait être
notre luxe
[Musique]
une femme doit recevoir une éducation
qui ne devrait pas être la même que
celle des hommes
si nous enseigne comme on tourne le
monde
ils ont perpétré contre je ne sais pas
comment vous faites pour tenir à deux
dans un lieu si petit allende mort
je n'ai qu'un objectif c'est de pouvoir
devenir un grand écrivain et il n'y a
rien que vous puissiez faire pour mais
repêché
oh mon dieu elle est vraiment folle bien
sûr qu'elle est folle c'est emilie dit
on faire tu vas devoir arrêter ce genre
de saint jacques
[Musique]
je fasse quelque chose homo désespéré
maintenant
conduit pas comme une morte alors que tu
es en vie
si vous voulez obtenir quelque chose
vous devez tendre la main et vous en
emparer
cette forte et sera la seule dickinson
dont on parlera dans 200 jeunes ont fait
la promesse
c'était quand même un très bel
enterrement dans mon époque le mien
quand la salle est pleine et que la
lumière s'éteint
le temps se suspend tout d'un coup
on attend tous que la magie commence
[Musique]
sap a été retenue il faut juste que
quelqu'un me donne ma chance dit vous
n'avez pas besoin d'un pianiste pas
depuis trente ans
et voici notre chorégraphe jambes de
rêve
vous avez raté votre pirouette je n'ai
rien d'autre à voir
alors je vais leur faire bien
[Musique]
je veux passer une audition tu te
souviens que c'est un livreur
oui il nous faut ni vedette la vedette
c'est la danse c'est un nom sur la fiche
qui tenir les gens
kyle a signé le contrat elle reprend son
rôle dans free dax barlow j'ai besoin
que tu m'aides avec calme et danseurs
d'ensemble non pas d'évolution carrière
ils ne sont jamais sur le devant de la
scène
j'ai besoin que le spectacle soit
flamboyant qui nous emporte tout du long
moi aussi si elle est phénoménale
qu'est ce qui se passe exactement entre
vendeurs et toi elle s'est mise à nu
pour toi pendant la répétition
[Musique]
tu es fort et tu as beaucoup de talent
montrez nous ce que tu vaux
[Musique]
tu vas m'inviter ou bien
merde m'apprécient pas beaucoup elle
aime pas grand monde passe me prendre à
18h connais ton vraiment ses parents
c'est facile d'oublier qu'un jour nos
parents étaient jeunes qui l'ont fait
des trucs dingues
j'ai rencontré cette femme ans d'après
des jours qui qu'est ce que tu dis
quelles sont les chances que deux
générations se rencontrent exactement au
même endroit
je pensais bien connaître les miens mais
je me trompais pas aux camions
tu piges
[Musique]
c'est vite dit
je suis
elle pousse mais ouais
ok
[Musique]
je m'appelle masi et c'est l'histoire de
mes parents
[Musique]
tout sera fait pour que le peuple
algérien et la parole dans l'apaisement
[Musique]
une série que dans un sens
bonjour à quelqu'un
quand on fait l'armée son métier en 3
mètres sont claude côté c'est le prix ap
pas de la série
c
méthode
[Musique]
autant
pourquoi pas je suis pour la vérité
peu importe qui la raconte je suis pour
la justice peu importe en faveur de qui
elle trouvait
18 ans 10 mois et 24 jours c'est le
temps que warren qu'elle va passer en
prison jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour le
meurtre de chuck permane
j'ai contribué à sceller le destin de
warren avec une série d'articles a donc
jeté un homme innocent en prison
elle joué un rôle
pour le faire accuser
oh
[Musique]
à
rae
tu m'a dépeint comme un psychopathe pour
y était maintenant je vis dans un
bâtiment en clinton qui mentent
connaissent bien
j'ai senti vote mensonge avant même que
vous ayez commencé à l'ouvrir
une mère et ses deux filles pouvait-elle
dormir pendant que se jouait un drame
aussi et on n'a jamais retrouvé l'armé
du crime
c'est du cash laisse tomber bon je vais
vraiment te pourrir la vie ici
via monstres cachés en chacun de nous tu
plais trop peur
et le vôtre vous avez quoi l'intérieur
joue avec la vie de certaines personnes
est-ce que des prêtes à faire face aux
conséquences tu crois que la justice à
verser un jour tous les secrets dit à
pop y parle elle de me lâcher vous avez
emmerder sa famille
aucune idée de ce que j'ai fait pour
cette famille
reçoit nsa désordre
je dois savoir la vérité sur ce qui
s'est passé cette nuit
ils vont la voir leur spectacle
[Musique]
once upon a time
tant de monde
ap québec
[Musique]
oui